[Aplausos]
gracias muy buenos ya tenga todos feliz
de estar con ustedes en esta universidad
tan prestigiosa en un evento donde
podemos expresar lo que sentimos donde
podemos contar nuestras historias dónde
podemos inspirar a muchos de ustedes y
donde también podemos aprender de todos
los ponentes que están hoy en día aquí
me siento súper orgullosa estar acá con
ustedes en esta casa de estudios
contarles lo que hago como madre como
profesional como mujer como periodista
deportiva como esposa como donante de
órganos y lo más importante
amante de la vida quienes aquí no son
amantes de la vida este pasaje que no
sabemos cuánto va a durar pero que lo
vivimos a plenitud o tratamos de vivirlo
a plenitud me considero una persona
feliz no sólo sonrío como dice regina me
considero una persona feliz inmensamente
feliz sumamente feliz en lo personal
tengo un imperfecto matrimonio muy feliz
tengo como madre me siento totalmente
realizada y en el área laboral en los
medios de comunicación trabajo en los
medios de comunicación que siempre fue
mi sueño desde niña también tuve el
sueño de ser cantante pero toda esa
información se las puedo encontrar en
otro texto porque me reinventé y seguí
el primer el primer sueño que tuve que
fue estudiar comunicación
dedicarme a los medios de comunicación
que los amo que los adoro la radio la
televisión ahora las plataformas
digitales que se han convertido pues en
nuestros nuevos medios de comunicación y
también muy importante tengo el
privilegio de recibir el cariño de
muchísima gente a través de las redes
sociales esta plataforma que nos
mantiene conectados con muchísima gente
en muchísimos ámbitos afortunadamente me
ha tocado vivir en una época de
increíble paridad de género
increíble paridad de género y es que
porque soy mujer y puedo opinar sobre el
juego del hombre
por mi opinión sobre por ejemplo hoy
aquí estando en monterrey
forme opinión de tigres un equipo que se
ha convertido en el equipo de la década
en la liga mx y por supuesto puedo
debatirlo con ustedes
también a través de youtube a través de
las redes sociales y siempre recibo un
respetuoso debate cuando digo mi opinión
en relación a que tigres pues puede ser
uno de los equipos la década
en qué momentos salieron de la cocina el
más repetido de todos los señores
siempre lo recibo dt a la cocina perra
lucy duele si duele pero no se
acostumbra a vivir con ese tipo de cosas
pero bueno esos mensajes no son tan
gratificantes como otros que te mandan a
las mujeres no siempre nos valoran por
lo que sabemos
pero mi mamá desde muy chiquita me dijo
que pues yo era muy guapa y yo le creo
porque mi mamá
pero
a lo mejor eso también me ayuda a que la
gente pues entienda lo que yo le quiero
dar a través de mis mensajes y de mis
opiniones
y adriana lo único bueno que tiene es tu
cuerpecito porque lo que dices nada que
ver
me queda claro
está bien recapitulemos entonces estos
twitteros que me decidieron mandar el
día de hoy soy mujer no me valoran por
lo que sé no me valoran por tampoco por
lo que he aprendido por lo que he
trabajado y por lo que me he preparado
tampoco por la supuesta cara bonita que
mi mamá me dice que siempre tengo
seguramente trabajo en una empresa todo
de la comunicación y la gente
seguramente me va a respetar por eso
la vendida de televisa
también me llegan este tipo de mensajes
pero bueno ya yo creo que esto la gente
de producción está
haciendo un juego aquí o que resulta que
no me respetan y por mi conocimiento ni
por mi cara bonita ni por la empresa en
la que trabajo que más faltaría para
este tipo de mensajes
tienes que ser extranjera
aparte quitándole un lugar a un mexicano
que sabemos más de este espacio
ya basta ya basta de producción les
agradezco que pongan algo bueno porque
alguien aquí me crea que viene
inspirarlos que vine a mostrarles mi
mis ni nadie ni piernas ni cadenas pero
lindo rostro yo les diré que me va a
tener razón y quise empezar con este
tipo de sketch para que se verán un poco
para tener un ice breakers como dice en
inglés para que se den cuenta de todo lo
que estamos expuestos cuando trabajamos
en medio de comunicación cuando somos
personas públicas no podemos evitar este
tipo de mensajes vivimos en un momento
donde la gente se cree juez y a través
de una red social a través de una
computadora de un ipad de un teléfono te
pueden decir lo que ellos creen y hasta
sus propias frustraciones querer pasaron
las a nosotros mi único consejo
es que no traten de agradar a nadie
agradece ustedes mismos
en su cuenta de lo que quieren hacer en
su cuenta de que cada uno de ustedes
tiene algo que haga este mundo cada uno
de ustedes tiene algo que darle a méxico
no todos nos van a amar nos todos nos
van a odiar no vamos a hacer tan buenos
como nos dicen en redes sociales tampoco
vamos a hacer tan malos como nos dicen
en redes sociales
sientan si ustedes lo que tienen que ser
para dar en este mundo mi consejo no
trabajen para recibir el reconocimiento
de nadie su propio reconocimiento es el
que tienen que tener es el que los va a
ser feliz y no sonreír como ese régimen
yo les dije que era inmensamente feliz
cuando inicio esta charla y lo soy todo
lo que he hecho en mi carrera todo lo
que me llevaba a estar donde estoy en la
empresa en la que trabajo estoy muy
orgullosa de poder haber llegado siendo
extranjera a una de las empresas de
comunicación más importante en
latinoamérica no solo en mexico
además tener la oportunidad de analizar
de debatir el deporte que es lo que más
amo en esta vida
por eso les propongo algo vamos a
iniciar de nuevo
por qué
a la incomparable adriana gonzález
jamaica medio
[Música]
antes de nada
el proceso
inician y es bien como dijeron antes de
iniciar esta charla estuve ocho años
trabajando en una empresa tan reconocida
como ésta no solo en méxico a nivel
internacional tuve
el privilegio de haber trabajado con
alguien como david faitelson debatir con
él mandarlo a callar de vez en cuando
aprender de él aprender las cosas
positivas que puede dar fighter sobre la
comunicación y aprender las cosas
negativas lo que no quería tampoco ser y
aprender de estudios por centre estudio
en acción y es bien después me vine para
univision y hoy en día estoy
compartiendo y lo que significa esta
nueva fusión de tvn que es univision y
televisa juntos así que bueno soñar
trabajar luchar llegar a inspirar esos
son las cinco palabras que creo que son
claves para esta día para dejarles a
ustedes algo en el cerebro en esa
psiquis de poder luchar por lo que uno
quiere tengo casi 15 años en la
comunicación es muy disfrutable por
supuesto
pero son 15 años que ha sido complicado
también 15 años que los medios me han
dado
qué es lo que quiero y lo que no quiero
en la vida
soy tan apasionada en hacer las cosas
que quiero que también ese tipo de
pasión me gusta transmitírselos a la
gente y creo que lo hago otra vez todos
los días cada vez que estoy en un
programa de televisión cuando recibí la
invitación para formar parte de este
texto me emocioné dije guau por contar
mi historia puedo inspirar a alguien
alguien me puede escuchar alguien puede
saber lo que significa y los pasos para
poder ser una periodista deportivo mujer
y no morir en el intento
para mí ha sido un reto profesional muy
grande llegar a méxico y poder
posicionarme en un tipo de mercado tan
complicado como éste
a veces creo que nosotros somos los
responsables y no solo en las mujeres
los hombres creo que somos los
responsables todos de poder cambiar esta
sociedad
de poder ser corresponsables
en buscar lo que queremos
cambiar a qué me refiero
estos gráficos que vamos a empezar a ver
nos proporciona la energía y son
gráficos de 2018 nos muestra la brecha
que aún existe en salarios de mujeres en
comparación a los salarios de hombres en
mexico
ven que siempre estamos por debajo no
pero una de las cosas que más me ha
impresionado y es una realidad es una
estadística no es mi opinión no es la
opinión de ustedes es una realidad son
datos son números que nos muestran que
sí que en el sector de funcionarios y
directivos de los sectores públicos
privados sociales o sea los altos cargos
de los diferentes rubros en méxico si
pueden llegar mujeres y hay muchas hay
89.4 mujeres
pero
no ganan lo mismo que un hombre aún
realizando la misma labor aún realizando
y teniendo los mismos conocimientos que
cualquier otro hombre
mi mensaje es este vamos a cambiar los
vamos ustedes hombres todos los que
están aquí todos tenemos que ser
corresponsables junto a las mujeres
cambiarlo cómo lo podemos cambiar
siendo protagonistas no solo siendo
testigos estando y dándonos cuenta que
nosotros tenemos que hacer nuestra parte
del otro lado está la mujer no no no
quiero yo no quiero pensar ni quiero que
ustedes piense que soy vista
victimizando este género porque no es
creo que tenemos que trabajar juntos
para como sociedad no repetir los mismos
parámetros que han llevado a que estos
números sigan siendo la realidad que
vivimos no solo en mexico en muchísimos
otros países de latinoamérica
entonces hablemos qué pasos chicas
deberíamos seguir para realizar la labor
de una periodista deportiva la primera
pasos a seguir
la preparación esto aplica para los dos
obviamente para los dos géneros la
valentía
la resiliencia y la 4 más preparación
una preparación prepárense como nadie
aprendan a identificar sus virtudes en
que son buenos en que son malos
aprendamos a diferenciar entre lo que
quiero entre lo que soñé
y en las energías que puedes tener y
poner para ser útil
se quieren dedicar aquí cuántos a la
comunicación es que estamos en la
facultad de comunicaciones de
humanidades cuántos aquí levanten la
mano se quisieran dedicar a la
comunicación
y mujeres cuantos se quieren dedicar a
lo deportivo me imagino que esta ciudad
tan futbolera habrá muchos que quieran
dedicarse al medio de la comunicación
deportiva
todas esas manos a mi me inspiran a mí
me hacen sentir de que si estoy aquí
contándoles esta historia es porque
inspira cada uno de ustedes
a través de mi trabajo
para que se quisieran dedicar a estos
dos valentía sean valientes afrontan el
miedo es normal tener miedo el medio es
libre siempre vamos a tener miedo al qué
dirán
pero hay que afrontarlo la época que nos
tocó vivir no nos podemos hacer víctimas
nos tocó vivir esta época como en otro
momento a otras mujeres le tocó vivir
otra más complicado nosotros hemos
conseguido espacios hemos conseguido
nichos que antes no estaban ni siquiera
supuestos a que las mujeres lo pudieran
hacer así que
no se dejen caer por los mensajes no se
dejen guiar por los obstáculos
el miedo es libre como dije y es libre
sentirlo y es rico sentir miedo es rico
estar allá afuera y sentir nervios esas
maripositas en el estómago antes de
salir a presentarme ante ustedes porque
generalmente me presento
ante una cámara de televisión pero en la
cámara de televisión no ves a 200
personas aquí y que el foco seas tú el
foco siempre es el fútbol o el béisbol o
la nba o los jugadores hoy sentí miedo y
centenario de salir a hablar con ustedes
a inspirarlos a que entiendan que
estamos en un mundo
que muchos obstáculos vamos a tener
pero está en nosotros y en la
resiliencia que tengamos de seguir
trabajando por ellos en esta carrera son
más las veces que nos dice no no puedes
no nos llamen nosotros te llamaremos son
muchas las audiciones que nos tocan ahí
y son muchos los castings son muchas las
entrevistas le tienes que gustar a uno
a uno
para que te den la oportunidad de llegar
pero que volvemos al punto a la
preparación cuando la oportunidad llegue
hay que estar preparado porque no sabes
cuándo va a llegar la oportunidad
más preparación nunca dejen de
prepararse de consumir deportes si
quieren hacer deportes o consumir
cualquier otro tipo de rubro en el que
se quieran dedicar
hay que consumir deportes no todos los
medios son posibles y de todos de todos
se aprende hasta del amigo que conociste
en la facultad el amigo que conociste en
la clase de comunicación el señor que
está vendiendo té en la tienda de
cualquiera aprendemos algo no hay otra
fórmula y me falta algo no importa si
eres comunicólogo si eres médico si eres
ingeniero si quieres ser presidente de
la república
esta charla lleva un título con cinco
palabras que son claves para alcanzar
ese éxito que son soñar trabajar luchar
llegar
e inspirar
y me quiero parar un momento y con
inspirar
la mejor de mis enseñanzas que les puedo
compartir es que si logramos inspirar al
de al lado
vienen de lado
en el de lado
y puedo aprender de él
a tu compañero de clase a tu compañero
de oficina a un familiar a un amigo
en ese momento se van a sentir plenos se
van a sentir realizados eso no se paga
con nada eso no lo paga ningún sueldo no
le paga ninguna mesada no paga nada yo
soy que dios me ha dado a mí la
oportunidad de inspirar a más gente
muchos pocos no lo sé
pero lo he hecho y eso me llena de una
satisfacción enorme me gusta y lo
disfruto
inspirar profesionalmente
hace algunos pocos meses me tocó
trabajar con valeria marini muchos de
ustedes la conocen
el día que trabajé con ella por primera
vez me dijo el impacto que tuvo en mí
fue especial la presencia que tenía en
la originalidad con la que conducía me
motivaron aún más a dedicarme a lo que
ahora afortunadamente hago
ya eso para mí es música para mis oídos
hay una pregunta que comúnmente me hacen
en cada entrevista y es que en qué mujer
te inspiraste
para trabajar en los medios deportivos
y yo dije guau hoy lo digo aquí creo que
nunca lo había dicho
me enamoré de la champions viéndoles
omar tapia me enamoré del béisbol
viendo del león en mi amado país
venezuela me enamoré del deporte gracias
a ellos y por supuesto si después
carolina guillén muchos de ustedes la
conocen que fue la pionera en los medios
de deportes a nivel internacional
y también señores inspirar y sentirse
inspirados
en haciendo la buena obra el granito de
arena podemos aportar a este mundo para
hacer algo mejor y definitivamente mi
historia más importante es que si hace
ocho meses le doné a un órgano a mi
hermano
leone mi riñón
y se lonas en una decisión que tome no
hace ocho meses una decisión que tomé
hace 25 años cuando me sentí inspirada
porque la enfermedad de mi hermano era
heredada por mi padre hace 25 años mi
padre lo trasplantaron una persona que
decidió donar sus órganos después de su
muerte una madre decidió darle todos sus
órganos
a mucha gente que lo necesitaba y yo
puede disfrutar a mi padre diez años más
me vio casarme me vio graduarme de la
universidad y estoy seguro que hoy en
día donde esté está súper orgulloso de
mí por lo que he conseguido y además
hablando de deportes porque era muy fan
esta persona me inspiró a mí a darle
vida a mi hermano y a poder disfrutarlo
también a él
hagan eso sueño mi mensaje es eso estoy
sumamente agradecida con la vida que me
ha tocado vivir sueñen atrevan se
imaginen en lo personal trabajen y
luchen y cuando lleguen inspiren
inspiren a todos los que tienen
alrededor al menos a uno con uno van a
hacer la diferencia gracias
adriana monsalve
[Aplausos]